needed treatment,
while six of the control group patients needed surgery or radiation.
When we looked at their PSA levels, which is a marker for prostate cancer,
they got worse in the control group but got better in the experimental group.
And the differences were highly significant.
I wondered -- was there any relationship
between how much people changed their diet and lifestyle,
whichever group they were in,
and the changes in PSA?
And sure enough, we found a dose-response relationship,
just like we did in the arterial blockages in our cardiac studies.
And in order for the PSA to go down, they had to make big changes.
I then wondered if they're just changing their PSA,
but it's not really affecting the tumor growth.
So we took some of their blood serum and sent it to UCLA.
They added it to a standard line of prostate tumor cells
growing in tissue culture,
and it inhibited the growth seven times more in the experimental group
than in the control group -- 70 versus 9 percent.
Finally, I wondered if there's any relationship
between how much people changed
and how much it inhibited their tumor growth,
whichever group they were in.
And this really got me excited because again,
we found the same pattern: the more people change,
the more it affected the growth of their tumors.
Finally, we did MRI and MR spectroscopy scans on some of these patients.
The tumor activity is shown in red in this patient,
and you can see clearly it's better a year later, along with the PSA going down.
If it's true for prostate cancer,
it'll almost certainly be true for breast cancer.
And whether or not you have conventional treatment,
in addition, if you make these changes, it may help reduce the risk of recurrence.
The last thing I want to talk about,
apropos of the issue of the pursuit of happiness,
is that study after study has shown
that people who are lonely and depressed --
and depression is the other real epidemic in our culture --
are many times more likely to get sick and die prematurely,
in part because, as we talked about, they're more likely to smoke,
overeat, drink too much, work too hard, and so on.
But also, through mechanisms that we don't fully understand,
people who are lonely and depressed are many times --
three to five to ten times in some studies --
more likely to get sick and die prematurely.
And depression is treatable. We need to do something about that.
Now on the other hand, anything that promotes intimacy is healing.
It can be sexual intimacy --
I happen to think healing energy and erotic energy
are just different forms of the same thing.
Friendship, altruism, compassion, service --
all the perennial truths that we talked about
that are part of all religion and all cultures,
once you stop trying to see the differences --
these are the things that are in our own self-interest,
because they free us from our suffering and our disease.
And it's, in a sense, the most selfish thing that we can do.
Just to look at one study, done by David Spiegel at Stanford.
He took women with metastatic breast cancer,
randomly divided them into two groups.
One group met for an hour and a half once a week in a support group.
It was a nurturing, loving environment,
where they were encouraged to let down their emotional defenses
and talk about how awful it is to have breast cancer
with people who understood because they were going through it too.
They met once a week for a year.
Five years later, those women lived twice as long.
And that was the only difference between the groups.
It was a randomized control study published in "The Lancet."
Other studies have shown this as well.
So these simple things that create intimacy are really healing.
Even the word "healing" comes from the root "to make whole."
The word "yoga" comes from the Sanskrit, meaning "union,"
"to yoke, to bring together."
The last slide I want to show you is from -- again,
this swami that I studied with for so many years.
I did a combined oncology and cardiology grand rounds
at the University of Virginia medical school a couple years ago.
And at the end of it, somebody said,
"Hey, Swami, what's the difference between wellness and illness?"
So he went up on the board and wrote the word "illness"
and circled the first letter,
then wrote the word "wellness,"
and circled the first two letters.
To me, it's just shorthand for what we're talking about:
that anything that creates a sense of connection and community and love
is really healing.
And then we can enjoy our lives more fully without getting sick in the process.
Thank you.
(Applause)